Have you seen the YouTube channel
Predictive History? So, it has recently
exploded and has nearly 1 million
subscribers. A high school history
professor named Professor Xiang teaches
courses that would never be taught here
in the United States. Courses about
geopolitics, conspiracy theories, and
secret societies. His courses include
how power works, how societies collapse,
how evil triumphs, dawn of the Jews. No
topic or theory is untouched and his
candid way of saying the things people
are typically afraid to say has created
quite the following. And the channel
went viral after one lecture correctly
anticipated the Iran Israel 12-day war.
He's now predicting something even more
ominous. He predicts in another viral
video that Israel will become the next
great empire controlling the entire
world. That all the events happening now
are a leadin to their ultimate rise.
what he calls PAX Judeaica. And he does
all of this from Beijing. Professor
Xiang is a Canadian Chinese professor
who studied here in the United States at
Yale with a degree in English
literature. And he now uh teaches a high
school course. Unbelievably, this is a
high school course. And he films it,
puts it on YouTube, uses predictive
history and game theory to correctly
predict the future. And it's been so far
quite astonishing. I'm really excited to
have this conversation with him.
Professor Xiang, welcome to the show.
Thank you so much for being here.
>> Thanks so much for having me, Kim.
>> I am really excited for this
conversation. I've been following your
work for a while. I've been trying to
get you on the show for a while. I don't
know if you know that, but I've been uh
messaging you on YouTube and all over
the place ever since I saw much of your
stuff going out there, but I think
you're in hot demand. A lot of people
want to talk to you, and so I really
appreciate the time that you're taking
to talk to us today. Um, I want to start
off with with what so your channel
Predictive History, which has just blown
up. I mean, now you have almost a
million subscribers, I think, on your
channel. You do such amazing deep dive
work, and you're using game theory and
predictive history to, I guess, predict
the the future, right? Using predictive
history to predict the future. So can
you explain to everybody who's watching
who's maybe not familiar with game
theory for example and predictive
history tell us what those are.
>> Right. So the idea of predictive history
is that there are certain patterns to
human behavior um that can be analyzed.
Um and so if you do a deep analysis of
past history, you should be able to
develop certain frameworks and models
for the understanding of human
development. And then you can test and
refine these models by making
predictions about the future. And so
that's what I do. um based on my
understanding of history I make certain
assumptions about how things develop and
depending on my accuracy then I can go
back and refine um these models and
frameworks and one tool that I use for
analysis is game theory. The idea of
game theory is that um individuals
perceive the world as a game in which
they are trying to defeat other players,
their rules, their incentives. By
understanding the worldview of these
players, you can understand uh the
psychology and how they behave. So in in
our world, obviously Trump and Putin are
very important players and so by
understanding their psychology, you can
better understand um how they will
behave in the future. And that's the
very basis of what I do.
>> So you would have to know a lot of
history in order to do predictive
history toward the future, I would
imagine.
>> Well, you would also need a complete
view of history. So rather than uh me
specializing in a particular area of
history, for example, the Roman period
or the British Empire, I try to have a
macro picture of the entirety of human
history stretching from the ice age up
to the Pax Americana, which is the age
that we we live in. And um so in my on
my YouTube channel um I go over every
major period of human history and try to
show patterns that emerge from these
particular periods. And so I would say
in our age um I see tremendous analogies
between the Pelpaginoian war um and
today's America. U America really much
is a falling empire and the way that it
behaves is very similar to the how the
Athenian Empire behaved when it
collapsed.
>> Yeah, I think it it does seem many of us
can see that right now it's a a failing
empire or just a towards the end of it.
But this seems to be an empire that's
been uh shorter lived than historical
times. Why do you think that is?
>> Well, I mean the American Empire is
unique in that it spans entire globe,
right? So the Athenian Empire had
control over the Aian, but that was it.
And the Aian is a very small part of the
world. America insists on maintaining
hegemony throughout the entire world in
Africa, in South America, in Europe, in
in East in Asia. that's not sustainable.
Um, and America had tremendous advantage
because of its technological edge,
because of its aerosacy, because of US
dollar, but ultimately this is not
sustainable.
>> Yeah.
Um, this class that you're teaching on
YouTube, this is a this is an actual
class. I mean, you're you're look, we
don't ever see any students. Sometimes
we hear questions from students. So, you
are teaching an actual course and you're
filming it,
>> right? So, I'm I'm actually a high
school teacher and I
>> Is this a high school class? Is this a
high school class?
>> This is a high school class in Beijing.
Yes. Um,
>> so these are Chinese students. I'm
sorry. I'm just blown away by this.
These are Chinese students in Beijing at
a high school, right?
>> And this is high school level.
>> So, next time you're in Beijing, please
come to my class. You'll meet the
students. You'll sit in the class. So,
what I do is I go to class, I set up the
camera, I I I press record, I teach for
an hour, then I um turn off the camera,
and then I upload the video to YouTube.
So, what you're actually seeing is uh me
teaching my my class. And in the future,
what I'm hoping to do is live stream my
class so that students can actually uh
so viewers can actually participate in
the class as I'm teaching it.
>> This is a normal high school in Beijing.
This is uh not a public school. It's a
private school because in public school
um students prepare for the college
entries examination for Chinese
university. These are students who are
intent on going abroad to study in
America. primarily liberal arts colleges
um such as Carlton uh and so uh our
primary language of instruction is is
English and they need to have um an
understanding of western history and
western philosophy in order to do well
in in America and that's why I teach
what I what I teach.
>> I mean you're teaching something that uh
I mean I I never I never heard this or
learned this here in the United States.
I mean, this is so
I you're giving them such a completely
different perspective. I mean, it's
amazing. It's and and that's why I'm
shocked by this. For one, I'm shocked
because the level of material is I think
um I mean, I don't even know if college
courses here in America teach this kind
of thing, you know, where to this level,
you know. So, the and these are just
high school students and they're
absorbing all of this incredible
information from you where you're really
able to lay it out. And you know, I
notice in your videos you'll say often,
"This is conspiracy theory." You know,
just so you know, this is a this is a
conspiracy theory, but here's the
theory. And I mean, you're saying things
that are so uh raw and I mean, shocking
for I mean, honestly, Western audiences
and I don't know if that's just the way
like you could talk about things more
openly in China. That's not what we're
taught here. So, what gives? How are you
able to talk about things like
conspiracies about Jews for example on
your channel? Right.
>> Well, in your class.
>> So, um I grew up in Canada and I went to
Yale College for university. I I um I
was English major at Yale and so I had a
very traditional elite education. And um
eventually I discovered that in life
this elite education has failed me
because you look at 2016 uh Trump's
victory over Hillary Clinton. my elite
education could not prepare me for that.
Then you look at COVID, then you look at
the war in Ukraine. Um, and so I I felt
as though that my elite education and I
received the best education possible,
um, there were so many blind spots to
this sort of education and out of just
personal curiosity because I wanted to
understand how the world really works. I
began to um like many other people
during this time, you know, during
COVID, I began to really try to get a
better grasp of how the world works. And
you know, back then I was listening to a
lot of your um you know, um
conversations and insights. Um and and
then I started to recognize that maybe
the conspiracy theorists have a point.
So let's just you know for the just give
them the benefit of the doubt and just
see what happens if you apply their
theories to how the world actually
works. What you discovered is that
actually um their worldview offers a
much more um coherent understanding of
the world than the elite education. the
elite education I received at Yale was
very
um it didn't really connect the dots for
me and so I really want wanted to
connect the dots and so it's really
these past two three years in which I've
really engaged with um with trying to
figure out how what happened in 911 with
the moon landing with JFK um with COVID
with all these things and then I I used
this framework to try to understand
human history and then I recognized that
um if
you know with an open mind I can better
connect the dots and and so in my class
what I try to teach students is not
facts. What I try to teach students is a
certain attitude um a certain framework
for understanding the world which is to
question things and try to connect
connect the dots even though connect the
dots may lead you to uncomfortable
truths.
>> Yeah.
and and you're allowed to do this
and you don't get in trouble,
>> right? So, I operate in a in a very gray
area in China. So, public schools are
monitored very heavily in China. Um
there are certain textbooks that you
must teach from. There's the test that
you must take. And so, China has extreme
um conformity in its education system.
Private national schools are a gray area
because these students are going abroad
and this is a minority of students. The
Chinese government has not figured out
how to best teach um in these schools.
So, as long as you don't cross certain
red lines, you're allowed to teach
whatever you want.
>> So, and the other thing is that what I
teach in China is like offthe-wall. It's
so wacky that most people sort of find
it kind of dissonance and they sort of
tune off. So I operate in this like very
murky gray area and it's really weird
because as you point out I would not be
allowed to teach this anywhere else in
the world but
>> yeah yeah
>> it's incredible and you're doing it in
China
>> of all places.
>> That's right. And I could only do this
in China where again this great era
exists. um 99% of all education is
public and then you have this very small
percentage which is private and all this
private only a small percentage is
actually progressive um or experimental
and that's a school that I'm at.
>> So then my understanding from what I
know about the Chinese education system
but of course correct me if I'm wrong
but then these are international
students these are not Chinese
nationals.
>> No no these are Chinese students who are
planning to study abroad.
>> Oh really? Because I thought that with
pri with that kids couldn't enroll in
private school in China unless they were
expats kids basically
>> like they could maybe be born in China
and Chinese but I suppose they would
have to be their parents would have to
be international
>> right these are there are different
classifications so you're talking about
the international expat track right
schools that cater specifically to
diplomats of diplomats and you need a
foreign passport to enter these schools
um and then you have the public schools
and And in between are these gray areas
uh schools that are experimental and
international and which do accept uh
Chinese uh passport holders. And this
and the and this is a recent phenomenon
for the past 10 years.
>> Okay. So the Chinese government is kind
of experimenting with these experimental
schools saying we'll let some
>> happen and see what happens.
>> That's right.
>> Wow. That's right. Only in China. Do you
think you're able to say the things you
say and and speak so bluntly? I mean,
it's so refreshing watching your stuff
because you're you're so uh well, you're
academic. You're a professor. You're
there teaching a course. You're doing it
very academically, very logically.
You're sticking to facts and real things
and and even when you're talking about
the conspiracy theories, you're still
basing it on, you know, these are the
facts of what the conspiracies are or
these are the facts of the groups and
this is, you know, what we know about
them. Um, I mean, you're able to, you
know, you're so academic, but you're
saying things that are just the rest of
us cannot get away with. Even on our, I
feel like on our YouTube channels, we
can't actually, I mean, you're doing it
on YouTube and you're able to do it, but
you're able to just say things so
bluntly that everybody's thinking, you
know, I mean, but but people don't want
to say because if they say it, they
sound like they're well, you know, they
get called anti-semitic. They get called
I mean, are you being called these
names? Are you being called an
anti-semite because of your channel?
>> I I actually get called a msad agent
much more than than
because
>> you know one of my arguments is that
Israel will become the dominant nation
in the Middle East.
>> And so um I get a lot of comments on
YouTube saying that I must work for MSAD
or for the CIA. Also, I've been called a
CCP agent, a communist uh propagandist
because I talk so much trash about the
Western world and I talk very little
about China. So, I've been called all
sorts of names. Um, but I'm not I'm
usually not calling every though any
>> interesting interesting. Um, so, uh, do
you think that you're able to say the
types of things that you say because the
audience, like here in America, the the
United States is fiercely protective of
Jews and and you know, the if you just
say one thing about Zionism or a
criticism of Israel, suddenly you're an
anti-semite, right? So it's like it's an
overbearing over overprotective attitude
here. But I think more specifically in
the United States than even in Europe or
other parts of the Western world, but
Asia, I don't know if Asia's had, you
know, there's not that same relationship
to Jews that the West has because the
West has World War II and the history of
World War II and the Holocaust, that's
that was a Western war with the with the
World War primarily. I mean, of course,
Japan was involved in stuff, but for for
the most part, when the lens,
particularly when it comes to Jews,
that's a western narrative inside of
World War II, a a western story. So, is
that do you think that that has made it
to where people, Eastern people are
like, what's the big deal about a
conversation about this group of people?
I mean, you're willing to have
conversations about Muslims and
Buddhists and, you know, every and
Hindus and every other group. Like, why
can't we have conversations about Jews
now? You know, why not? I mean is it is
it do you think it's because of that
sort of attitude or what do what do you
think that is?
>> I mean the reality is that there's less
emphasis on political correctness in
China than in the United States where uh
in the United States you have to be much
more um careful and cautious about what
you say for fear of offending other
groups. But in China we don't have this
concern because China is um just one
ethnicity really. um it's a uh
homogeneous society and so there just
isn't that focus on pol correctness and
so you're allowed to say certain things
that could offend other groups u but the
red line of course is uh you can't say
things that offend the communist party
so there are certain red lines as long
as you respect these red lines you're
allowed to to say and do whatever you
want
>> okay so as long as you just don't go
against the government itself then
you're you're fine
>> I had a conversation with a friend the
other day and he was asking me, he says,
"Well, would you rather live in China or
here in the United States?" You know,
cuz I was showing him all these videos
of China and how amazing China is now
and all the I mean, the cities and the
villages. I mean, everything just it's
really the new world. I mean, just
developing really rapidly. And if people
really want to know the truth about
China, I really recommend those kind of
touristy pro like walking tour videos
where no one's really saying anything.
You know, it's not there's no narrative
around it, but you can actually just see
what places are like. and I like to do
this in my free time kind of all around
the world and explore through other
people's lenses. Um, and I was showing
him all of this and he says, "Wow,
that's pretty amazing." And then he
says, "So, but would you rather live in
the United States or China?" And my
answer was, "Well, I'd rather live in
the United States." But that's because
I'm a loudmouth political commentator.
But if I weren't and I were just some
like the average person uh who doesn't
really think about politics much,
they're busy with their lives, their
families, their work, you know, all
these things, then yeah, China actually
might be a great place to live. If you
don't care about government and
politics, if you're just focused on your
own life, then it's probably great. But
once you turn towards the government, I
still have family living in that part of
the world and if I get into
conversations with them online about
politics, they say we have to stop the
conversation right now and we have to,
you know,
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> Yeah. from that.
>> Um I I mean I mean I I'm very fond of
the United States. I went to university
there. Most of my friends actually
American uh because I respect the
open-mindedness, the generosity, the
tolerance of of Americans. Um, but I'm
seeing what's happening in America,
especially this past few days, and I'm
just horrified.
>> And I think this is a new normal. I I I
think that America is heading heading
towards a civil war, and um I don't
think there's any way out of the
situation. It's a very dire predicament.
>> Well, let's get into that now. The
predictive history of where we're at
today. Um, let's start with Donald
Trump. A lot of people want to compare
Donald Trump to a variety of historical
figures from FDR to Hitler.
Um, where would you say he who is he
actually most like?
>> Well, um, Donald Trump is first of all a
unique historical figure. Um, but if I
had to, um, pick an analogy, I think he
would be most similar to Julius Caesar.
So let's go over to some aspects of
Julius Caesar that resonates with Donald
Trump. So Julius Caesar became powerful
because he took his army into Gaul and
he enslaved the population. Um so
basically Julius Caesar conducted this
unwarranted war of imperialism against
innocent people which made himself and
his soldiers rich and it it made his uh
soldiers extremely loyal to him as well.
the petition the petition class in Rome
became extremely annoyed with Caesar and
wanted to indict him, basically impeach
him. And so Caesar crossed the Rubicon
and installed a military military
dictatorship. And so we're seeing a very
similar uh situation play out in United
States as well where Trump is creating
these uh paramilitary forces like ICE
and possibly National Guard that are
loyal only to him because only he will
support uh their brutality. Um you what
we saw in Venezuela is the rise of Delta
Force. So in the future perhaps Delta
Force will become the guard for Donald
Trump. And what's driving all this is
tremendous popular discontent where
people don't feel as though um there's
any hope of a better future. remember uh
in 2020
um the Democrats told the people as long
as we get we get rid of Donald Trump
things will go back to normal and Joe
Biden came into office um inflation hit
record highs and rather than trying to
make lives better yelling in the
Treasury Department gaslighted people
and told them oh no you know we're not
really in a recession um even though
everyone knew they were in a recession
when Putin invaded Ukraine uh Biden um
imposed sanctions that boomerang against
the American economy. Um Biden and his
people should have negotiated for peace
in Ukraine, but Biden insisted on a
full-scale war with Ukraine, which is
which has led to basically the collapse
of American empire throughout the world.
So, um there's public discontent, but
the Democrats do not have any solutions.
As the midterms approach, the Democrats
could be a party of of no wars, of um
more wealth redistribution, and instead
um they have absolutely no policy ideas.
And the only thing that they the promise
of the people is we're not Trump, and
we'll probably impeach Trump if we get
into office.
>> So um we're we're so right now the
choice for the people is not one between
democracy and monarchy. It's really one
between monarchy and oligarchy. And
given this choice, historically people
choose to pick monarchy because the
first thing that monarchs tend to do is
they actually u cancel the debt and
something called the jubilee. Uh and and
that's that's a very common way for
kings to cement popular support. So I
imagine you know if Donald Trump were to
become king and that is certainly his
ambition and he would cancel all debts
including student debt, including
mortgages uh and this would be
tremendous relief to to the American
people. Okay. So I think Julius Caesar
is the best analogy. Um and a lot of
it's just driven by incompetence among
the ruling elite. The Democrats, the
oligarchs absolutely refuse to admit
that they've done anything wrong. They
refuse to admit that um the America has
become a corrupt oligarchy
and they um have stated any political
changes including Bernie Sanders. If
Bernie Sanders had won in 2016 or 2020
then America and the world would be a
very different place. So um so it's not
just Trump, it's also this elite that
enables Trump. Um, another thing that I
will say is that what seems to be
driving Trump um is his thirst for
revenge because you know for Trump the
biggest drama trauma in his life is the
2020 um election against Joe Biden
because he's actually convinced that he
won the election. But um Joe Biden, the
Europeans, Obama conspired against him.
And um how well first of all you had the
George Floyd protests in Minnesota,
right? The Black Lives Matter protests.
Uh then you had the um CO um lockdowns.
Then you you had the um mail in ballots
that swung the election in favor of Joe
Biden at at the very last minute. So you
we can see much of what he's doing as a
revenge tour. Um so so he hates the
Europeans because he's convinced the
Europeans conspired Obama against him in
2020 and that's why we're seeing um
Trump being so antagonistic against the
Europeans. That's one front. Another
front is that you know why did Trump go
in and kidnap Maduro? Because I think
what will happen during the trial of
Maduro is that Maduro will tell the
people that Venezuela participated in
election fraud in 2020. he will present
evidence that um uh the election was
rigged in 2020. Um, and now what we're
seeing in Minneapolis in Minneapolis in
Minnesota is, you know, these ICE agents
going around and wreaking havoc and, you
know, how things will develop um in in
Minnesota is tremendously important
because I think that there's um a very
strong likelihood that what Trump will
do next few weeks is he will pardon
Derek Schovin
and this would set the nation on fire if
he were to do that. But it plays very
much into Trump's psychology. He's
trying to create as much havoc as
possible. He's he's really trying to
instigate a civil war with his actions.
I mean, how else can you explain the
fact that you have these ICE agents um
going going around America and besieging
average American citizens.
>> Um and remember these ICE agents, their
responsibility is to deport um illegal
immigrants. But guess what? Under Obama,
you had more illegal immigrants deported
than under Trump. Even though um you
have this paramilitary force called ICE
um going around and supposedly run up
running up immigrants. Um I think their
main um main job is to test out the
possib possibility of a secret secret
police in in America. Um there's talk of
there's plans to deploy the National
Guard to all 50 states this year. So, it
seems as though they're trying to create
the conditions for martial law for for
martial law.
>> How could Trump, if he has the desire,
you say, to become king? I mean,
obviously, I don't know if America would
go for an actual king. I I don't think
we would say, okay, you're we're
ushering in a monarch and the Trump
family is now the monarchy. But there
would be other ways to phrase it, I
suppose, and to still have the same end
result.
Well, I mean, um, let's consider what
Julius Caesar did, right? So, what
Julius Caesar did was he created a myth
of himself as this great conquering
hero. And so, that's why we see Trump
instigate wars around the world, right?
So, Trump is went into Venezuela. He's
he's talking about bombing Mexico and
Colombia. And he's talking about over
Guinand and Canada and Cuba. Um, he's
now considering attacks against Iran.
And even though you and I are horrified
by this, at a fundamental human
psychological level, this inspires awe
and fear among the people, you know,
which is what a great king tries tries
to do. So Trump is trying to present
himself first of all, first and
foremost, as this great conquering hero
who will store who will restore the
American empire. That's number one.
Number two is that as I mentioned, he's
trying to create um uh military forces
that are loyal only to him. you know,
Peter Hexev in September, last
September, you know, he said that the
new military doctrine is the word ethos.
Um, you know, we will disregard all
rules of engagement. We will engage in
maximum lethality. So, he's really
talking to a special group of people in
the military, which is a special forces,
Delta, the Delta Force, um, the Green
Berets. Uh, these are these are people
who are most sympathetic to, uh, this
sort of rhetoric. And so um they they
will eventually become the most loyal to
Trump which will allow Trump to engage
in market assassinations um sabotage
infiltration which is what he needs in
order to basically um um get rid of of
his political opponents. That's number
two. Number three is civil war, right?
So, um, to create to create a us versus
them mentality, uh, one between left and
right, Democrats and Republicans, where
you're forced to pick sides. And in that
in that situation, many people will
rally around Trump. Um, that's number
three. Uh, number four is to create a
national emergency. It could be civil
war, but it could but it could be
economic collapse as well. So,
basically, from a Trump perspective, the
more chaos, the better because it allows
him to consolidate power. Um, then of
course you have the issue lobby. The
Israel lobby is very much interested in
a war against Iran and you know Nat
Netanyahu visited Trump um you know
right before the New Year's in Mara Lago
and what happened right afterwards well
you have the kidnapping of Maduro you
have these Iran protests um you have
Trump saying that he will defend these
protesters in Iran. This is not a
coincidence. um this all part of a
larger scheme to um overthrow the Iran
regime and cause collapse in Iran so
that Israel can can create the greater
Israel project. And so if Trump is able
to deliver this to um Israel, then
Israel will give Trump whatever he
wants. So you know, Mayor Mayor Edison
has promised Trump $250 million if he
were to run for a third term. Alen Mus
has pledged $200 million for the
midterms. So the resources of the Israel
lobby cannot ever be overstated.
>> Everything you're saying it makes me
wonder. I mean in um when Trump won his
first term and there was a lot of talk
uh about oh Trump wants to be a king.
Trump wants to do XYZ thing and there
was a lot of Trump Trump wants to you
know usher in martial law. Trump wants a
civil war. Trump wants to be a king. And
and during his first term I thought wow
these people are really you know Trump
derangement syndrome. I mean, they're
just they're not seeing straight. But
now with this term, I got to be honest,
you know, I sit there and I think, so
there he is almost every day proving the
Democrats right. I mean, he's proving
those who were saying this guy is out
for power. He's proving them correct
almost every single day. I mean, he's
he's sitting at the White House
salivating over somebody giving him a
Nobel Peace Prize. like he's so um you
know he's just so ju just focused on all
of these strange things that are about
boosting himself. I mean it's just the
most bizarre thing to ever see. But it
makes me wonder, you know, when you say,
look, they there would because you've
got people around him now like you
mentioned, you know, Mariam Addon
and others, Alan Dersowitz were saying,
yes, there is a possibility. There's an
avenue for a third term. There's an
avenue for him to not give up power. And
they're trying to create those
conditions. And then the question is,
well, what the heck are those
conditions? Because only really extreme
situations would would that be
considered okay by the American people?
You have to create chaos in order for
that to happen. And it makes me wonder
now going backward to 2019 to the end of
2019 when CO first came around. Is was
that a plan of theirs? You know that
that and then they tried that and it
turned out a pandemic was not enough to
get us to stick with the same leader,
right? Uh we did still have an election.
We did still make that change. But so if
they tried like you say some sort of an
an emergency, well they tried one of the
biggest emergencies of our lifetime.
Probably the biggest emergency of our
lifetime uh which is CO at this point.
So what would they try next? And I think
you might be right. It would have to be
I think a civil war. I don't even think
war with Iran
>> would have would be enough because we've
been at war many times and we still
switch over presidents. So it would have
to be a civil war, right?
>> It would have to be a civil war.
Exactly. And all the conditions are in
place now for civil war. you have a
polarized information landscape where
people just live in their own bubbles.
So you look at the shooting in uh
Minnesota and both the left and right
are actually convinced they're right.
The the left is convinced that this is
an innocent woman who was killed for no
reason. The right is actually convinced
that she is is a a provocator. She went
in to resist authority. Um she did this.
She tried to run over the officer and
the officer did in defense. There's
actually no reconciliation between these
two sides. They all live in their own
social media bubbles.
>> But is that going to lead is that enough
historically? I mean, what has reeled
people to the point of picking up a gun
and shooting at their own family
members? Because that's what happens in
a civil war. Things have to get really
bad.
Look, the reality is that both the
Democrats and Republicans have um
certain paramil military factions that
will um incentivize and propel a civil
war. Okay, so the Republicans have these
n white nationalist groups, uh the the
Proud Boys, the Democrats have um you
know, Antifa. So these are street gangs
that they can deploy in order to achieve
certain political purposes. The reality
is that the oligarchy benefits from a
civil war uh because you have this
massive discontent and historically
either the people engage in a civil war
or they engage in revolution. So do you
do you prefer a revolution or do you
prefer civil war? Um, also right now
what's happening in Washington is these
this massive conflict among deep among
certain deep state factions. And I I
don't people really appreciate the level
of conflict right now in Washington DC.
And traditionally, historically, the way
that these um conflicts among the elite
are settled is through civil war on the
streets. The people are sacrificed in
order to achieve certain political
agendas. And so, um, I think that what's
going to happen is that, um, over the
next few weeks, Trump is going to is
going to continue to antagonize his
opponents. ICE is going to provoke the
people. You'll have random shootings of
ICE agents. Um, and then you have
martial law, National Guard, um, will
come in and these things can escalate
really quickly. And then you have these
um secret agents um um deep state agents
working among insurrection groups
organizing them uh encouraging violence
teaching them how to sabotage.
Um so um if you just look at movies like
Civil War and one battle after another,
it's really predictive programming,
right? They're they're they're really
tra they're really trying to get people
in the mindset of civil war because
ultimately at the end of at the end of
the day civil war is what benefits the
oligarchy. One because it prevents
people from recognizing the true enemies
the oligarchy but also remember that
America is $30 trillion in debt. And so
if your house is worth a million dollars
and you owe $10 million to the bank,
what you do is you burn the house down
and you collect the insurance money. And
that's the that's the game plan of of
the of the oligarchy.
Okay. So, it sounds uh I mean this is
pretty scary. It sounds but it but it
makes sense. Uh we see it all the time
on the national nation against nation
level that elites will sit in their like
Oval Office or they'll sit, you know, in
their war rooms or their uh and they'll
sit there and they'll they'll throw
bodies out of war. They'll throw
soldiers out of war. um and they don't
even think twice about all of the the
young men and women who are going to be
killed in civilians, children who are
going to be killed in a war. And so
you're saying that like a soldier for
the generals and the elites, um the
average citizen is actually a soldier
for the oligarchs. They they view us as
the same sort of they just view us as
soldiers and that we're going to fight
their battles for them.
That is right. That is unfortunately
right.
>> So what are the factions
that you can sense that are fighting
behind the scenes?
>> Well, I mean the major faction is the
one that is establishment, right? The
establishment faction which has been in
power uh for the long for the longest
time um especially under Clinton and
Obama are um they're nationalists. Um
they're elite. they're they are um um
basically these coastal liberal elites
um or or what we can say as a deep state
and now you have the rise of mega first
and mega first is supported by these
oligarchs like Peter the Ellen Musk and
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to overthrow the deep state to
establish their own power and I would
say these are the two major factions and
then the left and right faction are of
this or like the veneer of this deeper
conflict.
>> Yeah. So, it's a it's a deep state, an
an old guard deep state being ousted by
the new guard deep state that wants to
take over. But there's still going to be
a deep state.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> And the new deep state is more like AI
>> and surveillance and they're bigger on
it seems that sort of Yeah.
>> Right. Exactly. So, Olgard is
transnational capital, Wall Street, and
then uh New Deep State is Palunteer,
Silicon Valley, these people.
>> Yeah. Right. Okay.
Oh, wow. Well, do we really want to be
fighting for them, I think, is what
every average person needs to um you
know, and this I I'm glad we're having
this conversation. It's going to make me
think twice about falling into the trap
of the culture wars. Although it's, you
know, it's not a
it's one of those things where it's um
it's going to be hard not to fall into
that trap because people are being
killed. I mean, that woman was killed
and that officer's life is also going to
be about about to be ruined. Well,
except I think you're right. Trump will
probably pardon Derek Schovin and then
probably pardon this this ICE officer as
well. So, this ICE officer, I don't
think really has to worry
Well, well, there won't be any trial for
this ICE officer. And what's going to
happen is that this ICE officer is going
to invite to the White House and he'll
be a guest of honor for Trump and this
is this will just enrage half of the
population of America,
>> right? I mean
>> I mean like like Trump is like Trump
used to work in reality TV, right? The
World Rising Federation. He knows how to
push buttons. He knows how to piss
people off so that they want to actually
take up arms.
>> Wow. Yeah. Okay. So, I mean, it's going
to be hard not to fall into the trap of,
you know, is it is this what happened or
is that what happened and and everybody
fighting with each other. Um, not just
with that, not with just that, but
they're they're turning a lot of things
into culture war issues that really
should not be culture war. Like for
example, Gaza, you know, that should not
that should just be a straightforward
thing that everybody watches and is
appalled by, but instead it's a culture
war thing. um you know if you're now
you're a crazy brain rot liberal if you
are against what Israel was doing and
their plan to take over you know that
that that region
>> right so so let's
>> right so so I'm trying to interrupt but
like let's think about artificial
artificial intelligence what the what
the real purpose of artificial
intelligence is right now right now
artificial intelligence is used to
generate these silly videos and allow
students to cheat on um in in school
with CH GBT, right? Is that really worth
trillions of dollars? Um, you know, you
know, Open AI is planned to spend $1.4
trillion dollars on data centers over
the next few years. That's a lot of
money. That's a lot of data centers. So,
what's AI really used for? Well, AI is
really used for surveillance technology,
right? Uh digital currency, digital ID.
But not only that, but with AI, we can
actually create this individual matrix
for you where you are just inudated with
um with your own um in your own media
bubble which just reinforces certain
prejudices in you and and and and then
you're then you're provoked into action,
right? So look at chachi where you know
studies have have shown us that chachi
has become psychotic where you're
suicidal. Chip actually encourages you
to kill kill yourself. Well, you know,
it's that's that's you know a beta
testing of the true AI surveillance
technology in which everyone lives in
his in his own information bubble and he
or she is is being emotionally
manipulated to behave in a certain way.
>> Okay, let's talk about uh Pax Judeica.
So you say right now we're in a Pax
Americana, a Pax America or Pax
Americana, which what's what's the right
term?
>> Yeah. Pax Americana.
>> Pax Americana. Yes.
>> And we're moving toward a Pax Judeica,
which is what exactly?
>> Okay. So um the year 1688, this is the
glorious revolution. This is when um the
king of England is overthrown by the
nobility and William orange um who is
from the Dutch Republic he's installed
as the king and this is significant
because this creates the sovereignty of
parliament so parliament now is above
the king and what happens next is 1694
the creation of the bank of England and
the bank of England are these private
interests transnational capital um and
the bank of England they they are
guaranteed keep by the by parliament.
And so this crazy idea that these
private investors can lend money to the
bank of England and and um if they make
money they keep their money but if they
lose money then the parliament the
people um guaranteed their losses. So
it's socialized losses privatized gains.
Okay. So this becomes the new model of
global finance. Why this happens? Why
this happens is that in Europe at this
time the world is in flames. the 30
years war, uh, Protestants versus
Catholics and all these rich people, you
know, the Dutch Republic, the Huic
Empire, uh, the Catholic Church, they
need to be able to place their store
their wealth in a more safe place as the
world burns. And the safest place at
this time is is of course England
because it's being protected by the
Royal Navy. And so, um, all this capital
shifts over to England and it's stored
in the Bank of England. These private
investors have control over this
capital, but it's guaranteed by both the
Royal Navy as well as by Parliament. And
this allows for the creation of the
British Empire. And it it's a fantastic
model because um you know, you fast
forward 100 years and you have the rise
of Napoleon. And Napoleon is this great
conqueror conquers all of Europe. But um
Britain for the Bank of England, he's
able they're able to find seven wars
against Napoleon until Napoleon is
finally defeated. This and and then
England becomes the most dominant nation
in the world. Okay. So this became this
creates tax Britannica Britannica and
then you know after war II this creates
tax pax american Americana. Why? Because
if capital is able to move to England
it's also able to move to America right
and and and you have the creation of the
federal reserve. But now that America is
burning where do you go now? Well you go
to Israel. Why? Because first of all
Israel has nuclear weapons. So um Israel
will be safe. Second of all the Middle
East has been destroyed right? Israel
has no competitors. Um Iraq, Libya,
Syria, they've all been burned to the
ground. Iran is the last um on on the
list. And so once you burn Iran the
ground, then Israel has complete
dominance over the Middle East and it
can be just rebuild the Middle East in a
new image. And this new image will be
one of AI surveillance. So ideas that
you have right AI, digital currency,
digital ID, you're going to face a lot
of stiff resistance in America because
Americans like their freedom. But hey,
the Middle East has been destroyed. You
can you can now replace the populations
with Filipinos, with Chinese, with
Indians. And then you you can insert
microchips into the bloodstreams and now
you have this perfect, you know,
surveillance state where everyone is
martyed. But not not only is everyone
monitored, but their emotions are
constantly being calibrated, being
controlled by um by their surveillance
state. And so you basically have a slave
state. And then you introduce
transhumanism where you know all the
rich people in the world they can go to
Jerusalem and experience all this
transhumanist technology organ
transplants that allow them to live 150
years. Um so that's the very idea of pax
Juda Jud Judeica right capital needs to
move to more safe place which is Israel
but also these oligarchs they want to
achieve a transhumanist humanist vision
of the world and so um Israel has has
this technology but also they want to
create a c surveillance state in order
to maintain permanent control of the
world and that's p Judeica
>> well it's proven that they can't really
do that here right I mean co really sort
of proved that during co
I think that was an eye openener for for
many of us where I realized wow I'm glad
I'm an American living in the United
States where I can live you know I can
move to a different state at least you
know maybe my state's too harsh but I
can move to a different state I could
travel to a different part of the
country and live how I want to live and
so many Americans completely rejected
all of the mandates rejected the
surveillance rejected all of that more
so than many parts of the world I mean
we were shocked
Yeah. Right.
>> And that's why leading down America
because America is the greatest
resistance to this pack Judeaica, this
transhumanist AI surveillance agenda.
Every other nation has fallen, right?
You look at Canada, you look at Europe,
you look at China, everyone else has
fallen. The last the last opposition is
America,
>> right? And maybe Africa. We don't really
know what's going on there. I mean, they
didn't they didn't uh with CO I it's
like non-existent in Africa entirely,
but I'm sure they've got mechanisms um
to get them under control here pretty
soon. But yeah, you're right. The United
States is the last bastion of actual
freedom because there's just so many of
us that are so resistant.
>> So they so in that in that regard, they
cannot actually uh stay here. the money,
you know, if you're saying the money
moved from PAX Britannica to PAX
Americana and it's going to move again,
it's because they can't control the
United States. They can't surveil it
fast enough. Like there's just too many
issues with that. So, they've got to go
where they're where they can do all of
that. And you're right. I mean, Israel
has been one of the first to implement
uh many of these many of these measures
and they always do it under the guise of
security.
>> Well, Gaza Gaza was an AI surveillance
state for the longest time. So, they
have all this technology in place. they
have all the systems in place.
>> So it's it's I mean like it's you know
it's it's it's a proven model. They just
have to scale it now.
>> So um certainly you know I encourage
everybody to watch your your series and
the one in particular it I think it was
secretive history. Is that what it was?
your secret of history
>> um series and then you had the PAX
>> and then you had the PAX Judeica kind of
the finale is or one of the things that
you talked about and that is a
frightening episode to watch. um
everybody should watch it, but it's
frightening because of how accurate it
it feels, you know, where it's like
going from the whole the Zionist um
you know, in a way that I hadn't even
put it together with the battle of Gog
and Magog and the
the world goes and tries to um you know
topple Israel. And a lot of people
thought, oh, that's what's happening
now. You know, it's that this battle is
happening now. A lot of Christian
Zionists, you know, salivate at the idea
that maybe it's happening right now
because that means the second coming is
sooner than later. But um but your
theory is no, no, that's actually in a
little while longer. Uh that's after Pax
Judeica is formed and the center of the
world becomes Israel and when that is
the actual controlling new dominant
center. I got to tell you. And then
while while I was watching your series
and watching that episode in particular,
when I went to Israel, um, and I when I
was there, I I let I left feeling like
and I couldn't shake the feeling and I
just felt like this is going to be the
new leader of the world. There's no way
around it. They're going to be
>> I went to Israel. I went to Israel as
well and I I came away with the same
feeling there. Yeah. I'm I'm Yeah, I
hate to say this, but when when you
visit Israel and you actually talk to
the people and you experience the
culture, they really do aspire to be the
world leader. They believe in
>> and they will and well and I just think
that they they've got the ability to
pull it off. I mean, you've got a
population of very intelligent people,
technologically advanced, developing
tons of different, you know, they've got
a culture of development of all of the
of AI, of surveillance, of security
state stuff. So, they've figured out how
to in infiltrate our governments and
control our governments. Uh, you know,
they've they've got an entire and
there's a lot of big questions like why
didn't, you know, there were other
players in the world like China and
Russia that could have helped stop the
genocide that was going on in Gaza. They
could have just, you know, I had a guest
on uh Larry Johnson last week saying
that they could have just done a
blockade and just said, "We're gonna
economically we're gonna economically
sanction you until you stop doing what
you're doing." But they didn't. And then
that that raises the question of why why
didn't they step in? What kind of power
does Israel have over them or what kind
of relationship do they have that
they're you know and also one thing that
I've always said is you know Israel this
whole ally our greatest ally that's a
one-way relationship. They will not
stand with us. You know, and this is
another thing I said to Larry Johnson is
I said to him, "Look, if war breaks out
between us and everybody, uh, which it
looks like that's where it's headed,
then Israel is going to play neutral.
They're going to suddenly become
Switzerland. I mean, they're going to be
like, "Oh, you're at war between China
and Russia." Like, we're friends with
everybody. We don't want to make, you
know what, we're just going to sit this
one out and we're going to deliver
orange juice. I mean, that's all they
did for us out of all the wars that
we've done. They delivered some orange
juice during the Korean War. Other than
that, uh, you know, and I think it'll be
the same sort of thing. They'll be like,
"Oh, gee, you know what? We got our own
problems and we don't really want to get
involved with all of you. Best of luck
to everybody. We're friends with you
all." And whoever in the end wins, we're
here. We're still here, right? So, it's
it's very much beneficial to them for
the rest of us to go to war with each
other.
>> Well, and they end up being the global
leader. Well, that's how they maintain
the pax Judea, which is very similar to
the Pax Britannica, right? Because
England is a very small nation. It has
very few resources. So, the only way you
can maintain power is by by sowing
discontent and chaos throughout the
entire world. You can entirely blame
World War I on on the British. I mean, I
know it's a Germans who who got blamed,
but it's really the British who caused
World War I. And, you know, the the
census deaths of millions of people,
right? So, Britain has been soaring
chaos for a few hundred years. Um, and I
think Israel will use the same strategy.
>> Yeah. Don't don't underestimate because
of size, right? You do have the UK,
Great Britain is a small place and they
still dominated a huge massive amount of
the world. Same Japan. Imperial Japan
had a lot of power. Tiny little place.
>> So, don't underestimate size.
>> Okay. So, where are we at today? So,
here we are. Um, it feels like we're
always looming on the brink of World War
II. For a minute there, you know,
especially when Trump was bombing Iran,
I thought, "Oh, no, here it is. It's
beginning." And then it and then it all
calmed down and I thought, "Okay, well,
maybe, maybe not." You know, and now it
feels like we're ramping back up,
especially with him saying he's going to
go take everywhere. I mean, what what
country hasn't he named at this point?
>> Um, where do you see with this
predictive history where who's going to
be battling who? Uh when does it begin?
Has it already begun? And who wins?
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I I would say we've been
in World War III ever since 2020 20 2022
when Russia invaded Ukraine. Uh because
that was a proxy war really between the
United States and Russia, right? Because
even though it was Ukrainians who were
fighting on the battlefield, it was NATO
intelligence, NATO targeting, NATO
special forces, NATO financing, NATO
weaponry was it was everything that NATO
had except except it its ground forces.
Um so I would say we've been at war ever
since 2022 but definitely this year
things will ramp up and uh the conflict
will go global. Okay so let's look at
certain uh key hot spots right so
Ukraine will will will maintain will
continue to be uh one of the major flash
points of the world because e the
Europeans will not give up project
Ukraine you cannot afford to give up
project Ukraine because it will go
bankrupt otherwise. So you have you have
European volunteers, European special
forces going into Ukraine to show up the
front lines because it seemed as though
Ukraine front lines will collapse at any
moment. Okay. And uh they will continue
to antagonize Russia and Putin. You
know, there was this um silly attack
against Putin's residents trying to
assassinate him a few weeks ago which
really angered Putin and Putin basically
said, "Forget this. No more
negotiations. You guys are hopeless.
This is all hopeless. Let's just finish
this on the battlefield. Okay. So, I
think Russia has basically has basically
decided that no, we can only decide this
on the battlefield. So, this war in
Ukraine will continue to escalate. Um
the Europeans will move towards
conscription, false conscription,
especially Germany. So, so you will see
the remilitarization of Germany which
will antagonize uh the other European
nations. Um Trump will continue to piss
off the Europeans. Um Trump will
continue to side with the Russians
against the Europeans because Trump in
his heart really really hates uh the
Europeans. So that's the European Russia
front. Okay. Um in the Americas, Trump
will continue to exert dominance over
the Western Hemisphere. The reason why
is that in April he visits he visits
Beijing and that's this is a very key
meeting for Trump. In fact, I believe
that President Trump and President C are
scheduled to meet four times this year
and the first will be April and they
have to work out a grand bargain. Okay,
so the conflict right now is that United
States needs China to continue to to
purchase US dollars because the US
dollars is this great Ponzi scheme and
if China switch to gold or tries to
internationalize the UN, this could
cause a Ponzi scheme collapse. Um but at
the same time, China still needs access
to markets and the great fear is that
the United States uses its navy to
embargo China. Um which is what you're
seeing in Venezuela today. Okay? So they
need to work out a grand bargain. And so
what Trump needs to show presidency is
that I control the Western Hemisphere. I
control Mexico. I control Venezuela. I
control Brazil. I control Canada. I I
control Greenland. That's why there's
there's all these provocations against
Greenland at this at this time. and
eventually have provocations against
Canada as well because the reason why is
that China relies on the western
hemisphere for access to uh silver,
lithium and copper as well as other rare
earth minerals which fuels China's AI
growth uh its EV industry, its
batteries, its solar panels. So its
entire high-tech industry relies on
these commodities from the Western
Hemisphere. So if Trump decides to choke
off China, then China's um high-tech
industry would suffer a great deal. And
so I think eventually uh China and
United States will come to a grand
bargain where um and so for example look
at Venezuela where Trump has said that
American companies will go and modernize
the Venezuela oil industry. And guess
what? these American companies, Exom
Mobile, they're not going to do that
because they have to invest tens of
billions of dollars and there's great
risk involved because Trump is volatile,
right? But
>> the Chinese will the Chinese will go and
invest all this money and modernize the
oil industry so that they can extract
this oil to feed their own economy.
China relies um on threequarters of it
oil from overseas. Half it half of of
its oil supply comes from the Middle
East. So there's a war in Iran, then
China's kind of screwed, right? So I
think the grand bargain will be reached
between China and the United States. The
problem though is Japan because as China
becomes closer to the United States,
Japan fears the rise of China, right?
And the great issue is Taiwan. So so
both China and Japan rely on oil imports
from the Middle East. And so they have
to go through the shadow of Malaa.
That's that that's a main trade route.
And so whoever controls Taiwan can
choose to embargo the other nation. So
you know the Japanese prime minister
Takayachi has said that Taiwan is of
vital strategic interest to Japan and
she's correct but that caused a huge
political ferror in China and China
right now wants it wants to blockade
embargo Japan deny Japan rare earth
minerals. So this year we're going to
see this massive conflict arise between
Japan and China because there's no way
there's no there's no way around it.
These are both nations that are heavily
dependent on trade and they will get in
into each other's way and so and this
conflict benefits United States because
both China and United States are heavy
uh buyers of US treasuries right so
Trump more weapons to uh to Japan so so
that's that's a play but but you'll see
increased hostility between China and
Japan even as relations between China
and United States improve
you'll see increased conflict between
Russia and United States in the Because
right now the United States is engaged
in piracy, right? United States is going
around and and stealing these oil
tankers from Russia and from China. And
there was an incident where Bella 1 what
one of these shadow lead tankers it was
trying to be it was it was being boarded
by the US Coast Guard and the and the
Russians intervene. So you'll see more
of these incidents
>> and in fact Russia will eventually
figure out that even though it cannot
defeat um United States in the oceans it
has to challenge the United States in
the oceans. So it has to build up a blue
water navy and China will probably
finance this blue water navy in order to
pro protect its own trade interest. So
the United the United States can produce
one ship for every 250 ships that China
produces. Okay. So China has this
tremendous ship building capacity and if
United States engages in this n in this
warfare against Russia and the seas is
eventually a war of attrition will will
will happen and the United States Navy
will will face rapid decline. Okay. So I
I see how this this this is how I see
the global landscape turning out. The
same time United States you have civil
war emerge. You have
>> civil war emerge probably in Europe as
well. You have economic collapse
everywhere. and then these nations won't
be forced to scramble for resources and
to protect trade access. So 2026 is when
things accelerate. Um Trump will
continue to be an antagonistic. He'll
continue to um piss everyone off, the
Europeans,
um the the American left. Um and um
yeah, I mean we're we're headed for a
very stormy um um for for a very stormy
time, a very turbulent time in our
history. But but this is a new normal.
Uh 2027 2027 will be even worse because
that that's why I think that the United
States will actually launch invasion of
Iran. So uh 2026 will be will be a great
conflict between China and America as
they try to reconcile the differences.
And once you reconcile the differences,
this will open up uh uh Iran for
invasion because great fear is that
United States invades Iran. At this
point, Russia and China will support
Iran and and there's a great possibility
that the United States will lose this
war. Um there's no way that Russia will
abandon uh Iran, but China can be
negotiated away from uh from Iran. And
that's Trump's game plan before he
launches a full-scale invasion of Iran.
Look, look, it's already been settled
there. There's already an agreement that
the United States will go and invade
Iran because if the United States wants
to maintain its imperial hijgemony, it
needs to control trade access. It needs
to control Iran. Um because once it
controls Iran, then China is blockaded.
The Bel and Road initiative is dead and
and now the entire Russian southern
flank, okay, the southern bottom of
Russia is open up is opened up and and
Russia could be outflanked. So um Iran
is crucial to the maintenance of
American hijgemony. The question that
the question now is when will this
happen and how will this happen? So I
think it will happen next year not this
year. Um and it need and Trump needs to
create this grand bargain with China
before he moves ahead. um Iran will also
be a major flash point in 2026 because
um right now these protests in Iran and
we know exactly what's going to happen
because we've seen this playbook before
in Libya and Syria. What's going to
happen is that Mossad is going to create
these insurgent groups in Iran on the
borderlands. They'll be protected by air
strikes and be financed by um by the
CIA. uh you have these MSAD agents um
leading these groups and you'll have
slowly economic blockade of Iran. Uh you
have sabotage, infiltration in Iran.
You're you're going to hear a lot about
Iran because the Americans, the
Israelis, they'll try to create this in
this narrative that any day now the
Mullas will flee to Moscow. Any day now,
the regime will collapse. Any day now,
the military will launch a coup d'eta
against Iran. any day now these Iranian
people will rise up and referral the
regime and look the reality is that Iran
is under tremendous pressure and so
you'll have this infiltration you'll
have these insurgent groups you'll have
warfare going uh on in Iran so you
you'll hear a lot about Iran in 2026
>> what are the chances none of this
happens and we just go on and live our
merry lives
and we just don't see a big world war
again what are the chances Do you think?
>> Yeah, I think we've crossed the Rubicon.
I I I think we are in a new normal. Um I
think it's very hard to go back to 2020.
Like I I know that a lot of people um
believe that, you know, in November the
Democrats will win the midterms and
somehow we'll go back to normal. But but
think about who the Democrats will run
in November. They'll probably run a lot
of blue dogs, right? These uh candidates
from the national security apparatus.
And what do they want? They want Trump
to accelerate these wars overseas. They
want Trump to attack Iran. They want
Trump to um antagonize Russia, right?
So, I I I I think we've crossed the
Rubicon, I I I think we are in a break
world.
>> But it sounds like with what you're with
the picture you're painting with this
world war is that it's Russia versus
Europe, it's Japan versus China, it's
Israel versus Iran. Um but the United
States is doing deals. It sounds like
like maybe to try to stay I mean besides
a naval blockade style war it sounds
like the US is I mean until the US has
to go and invade Iran on behalf of
Israel cuz probably what'll lead up to
that is Israel is going to have to
attack Iran be in a war with Iran
Israel's going to have to start losing
that war in order for the United States
to rush in and help them out. If if
Israel's winning that war the US won't
do that. So Israel would have to start
losing that war. I think
>> you you also see a lot you'll also
you'll also see a lot of false flags in
2026, right? So these attacks against
American interests in Iraq uh in Syria
and basically and also possibly on the
homeland as well. So
>> yeah.
>> Yeah, I mean yeah I I I think you're
right, but I would also add in the
possible false flags as well.
>> False flags. Okay.
>> And that Yeah. And that would piss off
everybody and then we'd say go to war.
That's it. Just like 911.
>> Yeah. So, so,
>> so other than the other than the US
going into Iran, it looks it sounds like
you're saying the US is going to try to
not go to war with Russia. I mean, Trump
doesn't seem to want that. Um, I don't
think we want war with China. And
actually, I don't think China wants war
with anybody. I mean, I feel like China
doesn't want to get involved at all.
>> That's right.
>> Maybe financing, but that's it.
>> That's right. You're exactly right. Um
yes, China will engage in development um
in financing, but that's it. It will not
send in troops anywhere. Um
>> look, I mean, if you read the national
security strategy, right, um which is
Trump's framework for the for um uh the
empire for the next um 10 years, a lot
of people believe that uh the national
security strategy, it's about creating
spheres of influence, right? right? A
multipolar world where Russia controls
Europe, China controls East Asia, and
United States stay stays with the
Western Hemisphere. If you actually read
the national security strategy, it
doesn't say that. It doesn't say that
United States will retreat back in the
Western Hemisphere. What it does say is
that the United States will maintain its
empire through a new strategy before it
maintain its empire through these
multilateral organizations like the
United Nations. And now what the
national what the strategy is to aband
the illusion of these liberal
multilateral organizations just leave
the United Nations which is what the
United States has done and focus on pure
power politics and it will use dividing
rule in order to maintain control over
the world. So it will not leave East
Asia but it will promote Japan as its
proxy in the war against China. Okay.
Um, it's not going to leave Euro, but
it's it's but it's going to overthrow
these liberal
uh European regimes and instead champion
nations like Austria, Hungary, and
Poland, which are more aligned with
Trump values. Um, and it's going to
fight in Africa for influence and
economic dominance against China. It it
United States does not plant a seed
anywhere. The United States will not
retreat from anywhere, but it's going to
change the rules of the game to meet the
new reality of the American empire.
Before Americans were shy about empire,
before Americans insist on the
rulesbased liberal international order,
and Trump's like, "Screw that. We're an
empire. Might is right. Let's just be an
empire."
>> Where is the safest place in the world
to be during all of this, would you say?
>> You know what? I have three kids. I'm
trying to figure out figure out the same
thing. Okay. Um, so look look I've been
thinking about this for a long time. The
problem is that wherever place you pick
everyone goes to, right? So like look,
everyone believes that New Zealand will
be safe. But if everyone's going to New
Zealand, how safe is that? Right? If
Peter Theo is building a bunker in New
Zealand and all this money is being is
is flowing to New Zealand, um, that
that's going to create a lot of conflict
and chaos as well. The reality is that
uh natives don't like immigrants. Uh you
know, so you know, you go to Europe and
you have all these immigrants that are
and the natives hate that and and it'll
probably create create a race war in
Britain. Um New Zealand is not is right
now under a lot of strain. Um you know,
the natives are being priced out of the
property market. Um so I wouldn't say
it's about geography. I would say it's
more about mindset. I think in this new
world, you have to give up this
materialist mindset where you know what,
I'm I'm going to make a million dollars,
retire, buy myself a yacht, and enjoy
the world. You have to focus on your own
spiritual and philosophical development.
You have to like learn things. You have
to watch the news. You have to be
resilient. You have to think about what
what matters in life. Um what what what
you have to recognize is that ultimately
this world can go to chaos. But guess
what? Most of you most of human history
has been chaos. But what matters to me
is my uh family, my friends, my
children, my community. If you focus on
that, you will get past all this chaos.
This chaos will not affect you if you're
able to build a strong community and
you're all focused on all on spiritual
personal fulfillment. Um I guarantee you
you'll live a very happy life if if you
do that. But if you're insistent on
like, you know, like I have $10 million
in the bank, so should I go investing in
gold and silver, should I move to Israel
or New Zealand or Chile? Uh you you know
you you'll drive yourself insane because
um this world is going to go crazy. And
if you if you believe that you can you
have $10 million, you can maintain this
wealth um during this all this chaos,
you you'll just go insane. You have you
have to give up the the idea that wealth
matters in this world. what matters at
the end of at the end of the day is
mindset, resilience,
uh spirituality.
>> Well, uh, Professor Xiang, thank you so
much for being here, um, and and sharing
with us your knowledge and the
predictive history, the game theory.
It's, uh, uh, it is a scary time that
we're marching into, but I agree with
you. You know, people live in war torn
areas. My mother grew up in one. People
survive. people if you focus on the
right things um you can get through it
and uh and and that is so I like what
you say there at the end that is that is
what we should be focusing on realigning
our values and what we what we what we
value what we want to hold on to so um
the YouTube channel is predictive
history I do have the link down below uh
definitely you know more people should
be watching you already have a million
you should have more than that you soon
enough um you're doing amazing work.
Really absolutely love everything that
you're doing. So, thank you so much and
keep it up and thank you so much for
being here with us.
>> No, thanks so much, Kim. It was a
wonderful first wonderful first
conversation. I I I would love to be
back whenever you have time.
>> Would love to have you back. That's for
sure. Thank you. Thank you again. Thank
you for watching this clip from the full
Kim Iverson show, which you can watch
Monday through Friday, 5:00 p. p.m.
Eastern, 2 p.m. Pacific at kim
Iversonshow.com.
See you there.